بحب اقول انه اذا انا هيك تكوين شخصيتي
بسبب الوالده الله يرحمه
بسبب جدتي كمان بسبب خالاتي اللي
كانوا بزمن ما كانت الحياه سهله بالنسبه
لكثير حواليهم بس هدول نماذج رائعه يعني
وقت اللي بتشوفي
ببدايه القرن العشرين تسمعي اسماء رائعه
مثل ناسك العابد
وهدول اللي عملوهن مجلات النسائيه
والاديبات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالفتره يلي كنت فيها بكليه الاداب قسم
اللغه الفرنسيه
كنت
يعني كطالبه محتاجه انه ربنا مجبتي شوي
ما كان في شاغر بقسم الفرنسي باذاعه دمشق
دخلت هذا القسم
وتمرنت
فتره منيحه بعدين لقيت حالي فرنسي
لما رحت على باريس صار شي بالمقلوب كمان
كطالبه محتاجه انه
رمم جابتي
لقيت انه في قسم عربي قبل ما تفتح اذا
في قسم عربي بالاذاعه الفرنسيه
لقيت حالي صرت مذيعه عربي
وبعدين فتحوا
ناخذها
وهيك
[موسيقى]
استفدت كتير كتير من كل شيء عشته بحلب
ودمشق قبل ما اوصل على باريس
طريف انه تذكرت انه في مرحله بحياتي يعني
المراهقه
قرات بازمه الصحيه بهاي الازمه الصحيه
بايد تقريبا شي سنه ونص قاعده بالريحه
الفراش مثل ما بيقولوا قضيتك كلها وانا عم
اقرا
وروايات وهيك فهذا كلياته بيعمل مخزون
يعني انه ما حدا هيك فجاه بيخلق مذيع
[موسيقى]
بحب اعطي هيك نموذج صغير على تربايه
والدتي الله يرحمها انا كان عندي اخين
صبيان كمان الله يرحمه
ما ربتنا انه
الصبي غير البنت انه انتو
واختكم نفس الشيء
نفس المهام نفس المسؤوليات نفس الوجبه
ونفس الحقوق
الصبيان بشكل هائل كانوا يعني وقت اللي
بشوفهم كيف كانوا مع نساءهم بقول الله
يرحمك يا امي قديش اربطنا كلياتنا مناح
[موسيقى]
قديش في ماخذ على فيروز والرحاب لانه
بيحكوا عن شي ماله موجود لا هو موجود بس
العالم المؤذيين بحاولوا ينسونا اياه انا
ما بدي انسى بدي ضل ذكر العالم فيه
ورحابني هدول
هدول عالمي
وانا اخده منهم ومن عبد الوهاب
مبدئين
دائما
انه
الراحل الكبير عاصي الرحباني بيقول الفرق
يكمن في التفاصيل يعني كل ما دققتي
بالتفاصيل اكثر وشلتي شوائب
بصير
الفرق بين العمل الجميل والعمل
وعبد الوهاب بيقول لا شيء يقف امام الجمال
يعني اذا كان هو عم يسجل غنيته عند اخر
دقيقه خطرت له فكره احلى من اللي قالها
بروح بتغير التسجيل لا شيء يقف امام
الجمال
خلينا
نتشرب الجمال والخير
[موسيقى]